entirely sure else crap isn't that just
beautiful when you just want to pawn
that in your house show to your guests
Pokemon go you're all obsessed with it
I'm kind of into it too I'm level 11 so
today we're gonna go outside we're gonna
catch some Pokemon PJ's coming to the
biggest Pokemon nerd in UK planet and
let's catch some Pokemon
these are my Pokemon so far these are
pretty high level so we got to take over
some gems [ __ ] those kits up
we found PJ's hot lady oh my god guys I
found oh my god
okay [ __ ] this up feeling alright I got
I got no way I'm not filming them come
on yeah tell me yeah
you're not so special anymore PJ I just
called a Caterpie so I think I am
whatever are you playing poker go to
honey cause we show you do it you catch
anything again to drive with you behind
you do we see the same poker scene yeah
no I thought the same road we found the
all the same Pokemon it's just so cool
this is it his real or something it's
almost like the Pokemon is there now we
just got hit by a car yeah and we're
gonna go to Z front to do some fishing
maybe I'll find some magic ops magic
curse
so everyone doing pokemon gold videos
are liking the los angeles to go to the
beach and it's so nice
okay [ __ ] the beach there's no polka
maze here oh my god
but you do bat more like moobot
we're closed we're closed guys what [ __ ]
you back up man
listen bah bah ha what keep oh you're
dead Adam yeah oh [ __ ] come on
God slaw man okay if I heard someone
yell sure is on like far in the distance
and I would run look out sad edgar is
used to pray I'm out here playing the
like virtual pokemons and then Edgar
look at it me so sad his tail is that
can we go home
just want to be he's not gonna be here
in the ran okay so I'm planning to learn
at this march of mermaids we're gonna go
there there will be pokemons there may
be a chair sir there will be relief
let there be a chair sir please please
be cherry sorry about that we're going
we gotta hurry up there's a time limit
here you stay here okay we're coming
back for you
oh my god be deadly better but running
out of time
yes
no time there's no time now I gotta get
this what do you think miss Marilyn he's
missing out on a ven a nap hey he's
gonna be he's gonna be depressed after
this you're gonna be very upset
slamming
homey get it weights what happened you
miss the Sven on that dive look forever
for that [ __ ] [ __ ] are you kidding
me your judge mister
where is it can't be devastated this is
what I get for being nice to fans this
is my reward
come on where is it gone it's taken see
you need to accept reality it's gone
accept reality
wait guys there's a Pokemon well is it
Frankie okay that's in there
slamming
got it got him cuz she got tangle yeah
there's a dangling yeah I don't know
whether kids cards it's Carville it's
good I think you angry at the Sakura
flowers smell it what's going on
Hey
that's a guy yeah
am I the Pokemon I was a trap I fell
right in the trap but I got a magnet so
it's caught I don't even like Pokemon I
don't even understand but it don't add
yourself in the vlog Brad what the hell
fill me it would be funny if you could
only hold a gym if you were there
there's tents everywhere
guys
I cut them all call them all I caught
all the pokemans all 151 look all 151
got em all good
why am I here I should be inside who
don't with won't go home got I'll see
you guys I'll see you guys yes I don't
need this
all right all right all right that was
Pokemon go I'm getting a little addicted
to this it's pretty scary it is a fun
game could it be better
yes but I still enjoy it do you guys
enjoy it I don't care if you like if you
enjoyed this video that way I get more
likes and as always stay awesome bros no
that's that Pokemon right tango factor
Pokemon was a real push my [ __ ] boss
gone wrong